hello folks
how's everybody doing and I'm gonna
throw trouble huh so we have a big day
today long day
Oh my throat clears first time I remind
everyone we have a conference the eighth
rational physics conference in Lusaka
Zambia and we've been around we've been
in Austria we've been here in Germany
Frankfurt Germany we've been in Scotland
in Mexico and Argentina and if anyone
who wants to host or prepare you know
the next conference please contact us
you can contact us here at toca car at
hotmail.com
okay and if that's the case we'll
announce it at the will be glad to
announce it at the Zambia conference
okay that's first the thing the other
thing is we uploaded the book okay known
as the rope hypothesis brings you up to
speed on the rope model of light and
gravity you can find it at rope
hypothesis calm look under books okay
you'll find it's a free book you can
download it's about but is about 160
pages and it'll put you bring you up to
speed on what the rope model is about
what this channel in large part is about
okay okay I got to begin today with an
apology today I was going to talk about
good ol Aristotle and I was going to
talk about Euclid and infinite planes
but some things to precedents turns out
several people had questions on some of
the foundations
of what we call physics Dan and it's not
the physics done by the establishment
which is something called mathematical
physics and which we claim has nothing
at all to do with science nothing at all
so what's the issue the issue is that
these people criticized several points
they said what do you mean you don't do
observations what do you mean you don't
do experiments what do you mean you
don't use math and yeah we don't use any
of those we don't verify we don't make
predictions what do you do if you don't
do any other what do you do we do
explanations that's what science is
about science is about rational
explanations we want a rational
explanation if it's not rational then we
don't care what the explanation is it
belongs to religion okay that's how
simple it is you might say well rational
is your opinion no we've defined the
word ration just like when you find all
words all critical words when you find
what science is what physics is what
philosophy is what rational means what
it exists means whether an object is we
define all those words very precisely
and yeah the criteria there's several
criteria I'm just going to mention a
couple for what is rational what is a
rational theory you cannot move concepts
around specifically none of the concepts
of mathematical physics you cannot use
you cannot move around claimed to be
moving around abstract concepts such as
energy mass force time charge or field
famous six words of mathematical physics
all those words are four-letter words as
far as we're concerned they don't belong
not only in science but much less in
physics okay so because these folks had
questions about these things which
people take for granted that's what they
learn in high school or in college today
I had to address that issue more so
because I had a little debate a little
discussion
with a gentleman during that past week
involving what I call physics or the
foundations of physics that's what it
came down to it had to do with gravity
okay
yeah thought about goes by the name of
Edie and so I'm gonna talk about mr.
Edie he was questioned specifically the
issue of whether experiments have
anything to do with physics okay that's
what he he thinks has to do something
with physic I'm saying experiments have
nothing at all to do with physics so I
didn't start will started with him
asking if I could explain why two
objects of different weights right you
have an elephant and a feather or
another feather feathers a bad example
and often in a rock right the elephant
weighs a little more than a rock a
little stone you let him go and barring
any we know from an experiment on the
moon barring any friction right in any
other interference the two objects fall
to the ground at the same time and he
said can you explain it and I said yeah
I can explain it and so I explained it
to him and he said oh but you didn't
explain it you didn't explain the
mechanism huh I thought I did in fact
what I did I pointed him to a picture
that illustrates what I was saying all
he needed to do was look at the picture
and understand the mechanism but here he
says that I have not explained it and I
could not understand what he could not
understand and so I said well what was
it that you did not understand of the
mechanism he said well you made an
assumption okay and yeah you made an
assumption the position what you did was
make believe and you know I said well do
I get points taken off the test because
of this
yeah I do make an assumption I need it's
required of the scientific method to
make an assumption about the invisible
entities that mother nature uses out
there to do her daily stuff like gravity
and magnetism because they're invisible
intangible they are obviously
untouchable unhearable untestable ice
malleable so you can't determine them
you can't determine their nature through
any kind of experiment you can only do
it with the money but he didn't
understand this he said ah but she did
not use real entities and so we got a
problem here it may imagine I'll give
you a four incident an example here ship
capsizes right and a buddy in you you're
the only survivors you can't end up on
an island so you're eating coconuts
that's all there is there and it turns
out this fella you know he's uh he's a
country bumpkin he's never been to the
city but he's watched movies you know so
he says you know bill
I've seen those cars running on the
streets he's never seen a car off there
in the country right they have seen him
on the movies I've always wondered how
is it that those cars run what makes
them move forward and magic I don't know
I don't know how would they do it and I
said well let me explain to you how they
move about how a car moves forward and
if you can explain - sure I can explain
to you how a car moves forward says okay
let's see and I say imagine it has an
engine in there but you're not doing
real a real explain I wanted a real
scenario I want to a real explanation
you're using an assumption well yeah I
need to use an assumption for you to
understand how the car moves forward but
that's not real because an engine is not
real an engine does not exist
so how does the car move forward well
the carbon was forward because of a
force see when we're in the country we
we put the donkey and the donkey pushes
the cart and that's the force okay and
so he says you know force is a thing but
an engine is not as a concept and I'm
trying to explain that the engine is
what drives the car forward he is saying
ah but that's that's an assumption
that's that doesn't exist that was his
argument innocent in you know I'm
exaggerating here but that is
essentially in the argument that this
fellow made and he the reason he's got
that idea he calls himself an
experimental philosopher Oh
[ __ ] was almost offended I called my
physician you know okay yeah or whatever
I called it huh okay so here it goes
this is this is how the dialogue went
okay he asks the Blues are all you'll be
is the broad ones are gonna be mine okay
it may well be that the theorist
must make a hypothesis but I am NOT a
theorist oh sorry the never confused you
I'm an experimental philosopher okay who
is study natural phenomena from scratch
one who wants an explanation not a
hypothesis so I try to give them a an
explanation and this is the answer I get
okay so what was my answer the first one
I want to address the issue of
philosophy because we had a little bit
of a debate as well over there in our
group and Facebook and we have the my
good friends one of only the one who is
hosting the conference in Zambia sumwa
and Dave and they they also believe that
I'm using misusing the word philosophy
and a lot of people do
and the problem is no one has ever
defined the word philosophy that's the
problem nobody knows what philosophy is
and here you have some the first few
that I found on the internet if you just
google it
you'll find things of this nature
philosophy is a way of thinking about
the world that's one definition another
one says philosophy is a set of ideals
beliefs used to describe behavior and he
mentioned Buddhism as an example another
one says philosophy is a science of what
of existence
he says metaphysics which is one of the
branches deals with existence
I thought physics was the sites of
existence I thought physics studies that
which exist and try to explain in I
identify what exists and here they put
that under metaphysics which falls under
philosophy and then you go keep going
ideas about knowledge right and wrong
huh
is this about morality is there what is
this is this about religion about what
you have to learn in church whether it's
right or wrong to kill an animal and
what is this about
and says ideas about how to do something
or how to live like you know living but
live that's my philosophy so it's a
recommendation it's an opinion that's
what is that what philosophy is
wikipedia says that the love of wisdom
comes from these are the Greeks ready
the study of general fundamental
questions about existence again
knowledge values reason mind you know
anything it's a jack-of-all-trades Asif
hears everything
whatever you study its velocity who love
of wisdom I guess that means you have to
sleep with the wise sage of your tribe
is that what wisdom is and I like the
Catholic Encyclopedia fest says the list
of conceptions and definitions might be
in definitely prolong yeah but what I
liked about it they did finding the foe
who wrote that article says the zeroed
in on why on purpose and reason which is
what we say is philosophy purpose and
reason ok what is philosophy philosophy
we have to define it because no one did
in the last 3,000 years since the days
of the Greeks no one has a
finition not only a philosophy of
physics or of science no one knows what
science is no one knows what physics is
no one knows what philosophy is all the
definitions are nonsense up there okay
and they all contradict each other this
guy says this and that guy says that so
we don't have a definition after so many
hundreds of years if not thousands of
years okay so here we have to cut
through the crap and say look this is
what science is science rational
explanation you have any rational
explanation it's not part of science I
don't care how much math you got behind
it how many experiments if you have any
rational explanation if you move
concepts around one of them if you don't
define your terms and you or use them
inconsistently if your theory doesn't
follow from your assumptions from the
hypothesis if you claim to have
explained and you only described there's
a whole bunch of criteria series of
criteria that we've defined for what is
rational now we can use that word
rational and the other one says
explanation not descriptions math can
only describe so math is not a part of
science because math can only describe
and people don't understand that they
say oh but tradition and this is what my
teacher told me you know Authority we
don't care we don't care how many people
vote for your definition it's not a
question of voting you got to get inside
the ring and fight for your definition
and that was the argument I had against
my two friends there because I said
philosophy has not been defined and we
need to define what philosophy means and
is you go to the Stanford encyclopedia
of philosophy and that a single article
survives it's all nonsense it's all
idiocy it's all opinion if that's what
philosophy is and what the hell what
what what do we need philosophy for
everybody's got his own philosophy no no
if we if we're gonna use the word
philosophy let it mean something and
that's why you know they they proposed
an alternative word which has been
around for a while since von Mises
Austrian economist philosopher I guess
you could call them practi ology and you
know I disagree with that we need to get
inside the ring and fight for the words
we need to fight for the word
physics first I mean I could also say
look I go to the mathematical physics
physicist and say what you're doing is
not physics what you're doing is
mathematics and some irrational
interpretation well that's what we call
physics
okay then I'll show you I'm gonna call
what I do X how's that know that suits
us fine go ahead go ahead with your X
and so I go around the world and say
look folks I'm gonna tell you a little
bit about X and everybody's you know
what the hell is X no I got to get
inside the rig and steal the word
physics away from these people I got to
especially you remove that word math out
of there there's no such thing as
mathematical physics there's only
physics and math is math math is a
language has nothing to do with physics
math is a language of descriptions
physics is what explanations you need to
explain a mechanism you explain them
with objects and you're gonna explain
causes what cause something to happen
that's what we do in visit philosophy if
it serves any purpose it's got to be a
branch of science and if it's a branch
of Hiatt science what does it explain
because science is rational explanations
well when it explains our reasons and
purposes why someone did something and
these folks you said let's use the word
proxy ology well they can use it I'm
gonna continue fighting in the ring for
the word philosophy I need to get the
Philosopher's out of philosophy they're
not philosophers they only have opinions
that I don't know what a philosopher
does you you go study in the university
philosophy I don't know what you study
because philosophy is like everything
it's just it's a way of thinking yes
your philosophy that's all it is it's an
opinion so what the hell is for like
what do we need philosophy for no
philosophy if it's gotta have some
meaning it's got to say what the
Catholic Encyclopedia says it's got to
explain purposes and reasons now we have
a useful purpose for philosophy ok so
yeah I'm gonna fight for that for that
word I'm interested in to word
philosophy
interested it onward proxy ology okay
okay so mr. ed continued and he said he
said the following said I see an apple
fall from the tree okay Newton revisited
I wonder if it falls because it weighs
okay would it fall more slowly if I cut
it in half right okay so I cut it in
halves what do I see every half falls as
Swift as the other one and as Swift as
the uncut Apple had fallen in other
words you take half an apple you take a
whole lap you let him go to the floor
and they both fought the same time you
hold it this one weighs half as much
where did they both fall at the same
time that's the question you must answer
it's about in question okay I want an
explanation of that observation of or
fact okay it is a fact that no theorists
this is he's already pretty predisposed
okay it is a fact that no theorist is
able to rationally explain the
phenomenon of equal freefall well not a
theory
no no mathematical physicists can
explain that okay let's get that
straight physicists can explain it a
mathematical physicist can I people who
graduate from Cambridge and Harvard and
all these Ivy League colleges those
people cannot answer these questions
okay because anyone who goes to big-name
institution goes there not to get an
education not to be a scientist they go
there be to meet people who are gonna
put them in the right places
and the only way you're gonna be put in
the right place is if you suck up if you
go up there and I mean how else you're
gonna get an advisor for your PhD unless
you you know answer the questions on the
test the right way you know what I mean
you can't you can't buck the trend now
if you want a job at CERN or it's lack
or at NASA or whatever yeah it is the
fact that a theory is a both no theorist
is able to rationally explain the
phenomena of freefall of equal freefall
why then should one expect any rational
when showing up anything from atheist I
don't know what he means by Thea because
it a theorist is an explainer so if
you're gonna give her a explanation
you're a theorist whether you like it or
not a theorist is an explainer that's
what a theorist is he explains and
that's what a scientist it and as long
as he does it rationally right okay so
let me leave this up there so what did I
answer to him
hope I left the right one yeah yeah so
what do I answer well here's my answer
to that this is the picture I sent them
okay
I said look all you gotta do is really
look at the picture and you'll
understand why two atoms in this case
two hydrogen atoms to make it simple for
at the same time
okay or have the same weight at a given
distance X from the earth a hydrogen
atom whether it belongs to an elephant
or a feather they have the same number
of electromagnetic ropes converging upon
it in other words from every atom on
earth you have a rope that is connected
to that atom okay aside from the fact
that every atom in the universe is
interconnected but here the earth is the
closest object okay and so the earth
every atom on earth that comprises the
earth is connected to that atom which is
at a given distance X from the earth or
from the center of mass we could say and
the same for the elephant so it doesn't
matter if the atom belongs to an
elephant or to a feather the atom will
fall at the same acceleration it'll have
the same weight and it doesn't matter
because one of the things no
mathematical physicists have figured out
is this the principle of equivalence of
mr. Einstein okay
Einstein said you have inertial mass and
gravitational mass and you said oh bill
what the hell is all that I don't
understand any of that very simple I'll
explain two seconds you don't need to go
to high school you don't need to go to
university this kindergarten stuff okay
gravitational mass pull inertial mass
push it's that difficult that's how some
food is what is pushing the other ones
pull that's what it is essentially okay
you don't need to know any more than
that for this and it doesn't matter if
the elephant is flying out of the earth
and the feather falling towards the
earth the atom the hydrogen atom at a
given distance from the earth has the
same number of ropes it has to have from
every atom in in that comprises the
earth attached to it and as soon as the
feather falls one inch forward towards
the Earth or the elephant goes farther
away one inch farther from the earth
their weight had better change like that
there has to be a change I hate to use
the word nominal in the air well I'll
use it instantaneous that's not the
right word but what changes is the
number of ropes effective ropes attached
to that atom that's what it is farther
away all the ropes come together they
act as one closer together they'd all
fan out and now you have more ropes
that's why you weigh more the closer you
are to earth and that's why it's
instantaneous here your weight changes
with location location is not motion
location is a static concept if we could
please the universe right God suddenly
moves his magic wand and everything
freezes where it is the number of ropes
converging up on that atom there you can
count them
gazillion you move it closer to the
earth it's got gazillion in one you move
it farther away from the earth it's got
gazillion minus one for whatever that's
what it works
that's why gravity is instantaneous so I
set them up picture okay set them this
picture and the other thing about it is
you know if you look to your right there
you'll see weight
what is weight weight is a static
concept okay and with the mathematicians
do they equate Newton's second law of
motion which is that first one there
force equals mass times acceleration
and they equate it to the gravitational
mass force which is force equals the
letter G which is missing there a
constant doesn't matter and then they
have mass mass over really distance the
mathematicians used the letter R which
is an error okay big error there but
it's distance squared and these two
equations they say Oh force here and
force there it's the same thing no
they're not because the distance in the
second in the gravitational mass
equation is not the same distance as the
one in the force times mass times mass
times acceleration
okay the distance is what changes see to
a mathematician - he's interested in
quantitative stuff he's not interested
in qualitative stuff so when he measures
a table it doesn't matter to him if it's
length or distance to him those two
words are synonyms why because he has to
unroll the end of the measuring tape to
measure the table or the separation
between two tables okay so to him it
doesn't matter for physics were
interested in qualitative stuff
separation is not the same thing as life
because life is the continuous matter
between two surfaces whereas separation
is the absence of matter between two
objects they're not qualitatively the
same and we do not unroll measuring
tapes in in physics that's something
they do in mathematics called distance
traveled which they confused with
distance okay and the problem here in
this equation is that the force in
Newton's second law mass times
acceleration
that's distance traveled that's not
distance and whereas the distance in
Newton's general universal law mass mass
over distance squared that that distance
is separation between two objects
totally different we're talking about
two objects versus the acceleration of
one object and it's a long story a
longer story in here I'm just
going with my little brush real quick
over that I've talked about in the past
but I can talk and I plan to talk about
it in the future but right now I'm going
to just keep going and here you have why
we don't fly out of the earth that's
good for all these flat-earthers who
believe that the earth is flat now the
earth is not flat buddies the earth is
spherical or more or less its oblate but
essentially every atom in your body is
attached to every atom on the earth
that's why you don't fly away and the
guy on the other side of the planet may
be a China versus the United States or
whatever he doesn't fly out because
every atom in his body is attached to
your every atom in your body there you
go right through the earth all these
ropes they crisscross and so the earth
can go anywhere it wants it to I'll take
you along with it because you're tied to
the earth and every time you jump you
are not stretching the ropes for sure
all you're doing is changing your
distance and and the number of ropes
that converge on you momentarily and
then you know that when you fall back on
the earth again they change okay and
yeah it's a different concept altogether
here's another comment by mr. edy just
continued in the discussion he said the
rope hypothesis if there is an
explanation of the phenomenon equal
freefall I didn't find anything relevant
I mean I show him a picture I'm just
trying to get him to understand the
mechanism and he's saying he didn't find
anything relevant anything that he
didn't find any mechanism he did or he
didn't understand it he didn't read I
don't know I don't know what he did what
I found is corroborating is
corroborating my view that it makes no
sense to begin an investigation of
reality with a hypothesis idea theory
see in in the religion of mathematical
physics all these people what they learn
is that a theory is in our hypothesis
these two words are synonyms a
hypothesis is simply an untested or
temporary or provisional theory
explanation and now we're going to test
it a little more with some kind of
experiment and then we get more people
to vote for it and the more people vote
for it eventually it becomes a fact
that's the way it works in math
that's not what a hypothesis is in
rational physics absolutely not a
hypothesis is an assumption what is that
well here we have it just so we can see
side by side what what it is different
hypothesis math magicians confuse a
hypothesis with a theory they have been
taught by rope and through authority
that our hypothesis is a theory that is
in its infancy in science on the other
hand a hypothesis defined rationally
hypothesis includes the objects
definitions the initial seen or
statement of the facts hypothesis is a
set of assumptions that the theorists
must make in order to lay the
foundations for the explanation that
follows okay you're gonna lay the
foundations of a theory let's call the
hypothesis you need to have the object
first I need to know what objects are
what which ones are gonna be the actors
is it a stone is it the window you got
tell me how the window broke I need to
know what are the objects so first you
got to point to the object and then you
gotta have definitions what do you mean
by this what do you mean by that bit see
by the word object the word exists two
critical words of matter of physics okay
and yeah so the problem with mister ed
is he he wanted to be convinced okay so
let me put that picture up here one more
time okay so what he wasn't expected to
be convinced he wanted me to prove
something to him to twist his arm and
convert him in and recruit him to my
religion that's not what we do in
science in science we explain
objectively so that the person
understands the mechanism in science we
must explain in physics we explain
mechanisms we do not we do so not to
prove theories or to get the jurors to
believe in them we explain so that the
crowd understands the mechanism proposed
so the reason you didn't find anything
relevant regarding the phenomenon of
equal freefall is that you were
expecting to be persuaded convinced
Roberta and recruited in physics we
merely explain any mechanism so that the
listener understands it and that's what
we do in visit and
understand that he thinks physics is
about you know that's what he learned
that in college that physics is or
science is about persuading he thinks
it's about preaching to the congregation
and saying let me prove it to you here's
the evidence this is the experiment I
ran in my lab and here's the proof so
that you should be convinced be
persuaded to join my religion that's
what they do and so when someone says no
no none of that is science what we do in
science is tell you a mechanism you
believe it fine that's your problem
doesn't concern science
thankfully you explain it a mechanism
objectively if you've got explaining
mechanism you need objects and for the
objects you have to make an assumption
and that doesn't sound too well with
them because they're not used to that
type of reasoning okay so mr. head
continues and he says he says your rope
hypothesis is certainly a clever one but
what does it say it just says that
things might will be they might well be
the way you describe them the question
remains how they really are said Newton
once I do not investigate how nature
might possibly work but rather I want to
know big word no nobody's defined
knowledge in the last 10,000 years but
he wants to know no means belief
according to Plato justified true belief
no one has defined it since no one has a
good definition they all have different
opinions about what the word now but he
puts the word now like you know what I
mean bite no don't you know I don't I'm
sorry
in fact I defined the word no which has
nothing to do with science by the way
that's why I don't put it in there but I
want to know how it really works really
really meaning he's talking about
actuality he's talking about what really
exists out there and so that's what
we're going to get into next and Jesus I
agree throughout your paper I find the
rope hypothesis the assertion of the
rope being a really existing option
used as a means to explain phenomena the
method demonstration therefore is
circular
see this is the problem with atheists
theists and agnostics they don't know
the scientific method none of the three
and I used to be an atheist so I have to
apologize I was just as dumb as they
were so I pardon them I forgive them why
are all these people eight see most of
the mathematical physics I think I would
say the majority at least are atheists
and that means they're irrational
individual they don't know the
scientific method they don't know about
science that's why they're atheists and
the theists are also you know well there
are your worse probably and let me have
the more [ __ ] agnostics you know
they say oh I don't know if God exists
or no I think I'm gonna go to the lab
try to prove run an experiment to see if
I could prove the existence of God and
when the experiment remains you know
indefinite you said well I don't know I
still have my doubts and I don't have
God exists or not
none of that belongs to science none of
that has anything to do with a
scientific method in science we don't
say I believe that God exists I believe
in the existence of God I know God
exists I don't know whether God exists I
know God does not exist we don't say any
of that
in science we say let us assume that God
exists let us assume that God exists
that can only be an assumption god is
not a theory the theory is perhaps how
God created the universe and you have to
make an assumption and the assumption is
God so he this is the issue here
the issue here is he says there will be
an a really existing object well in
order to know if it's a real existing
object for the purposes of an
explanation of a mechanism all we have
to do is define the word exist then
we'll know if it's a real existing
object okay and of course we define
exist real actuality all those worth
they mean the same they're synonyms in
physics in science and we define it as
an object that has location if God wants
to exist for the purposes of a theory of
an explanation if God wants to exist
that means he's gonna form part of the
hypothesis of the assumptions right
God wants to exist he has to have two
properties two attributes one he's got
to be an object so the question you got
asked a theist is not what is God no
that's not the question the question you
got asked him is God an object or is God
a concept does God have shape or does
God not have shape if God does not have
shape God is a concept and you're
praying to a concept and I hope that
concept has an ear and have good hearing
you know and if he's an object if God is
an object that doesn't make him exist
God has to have another condition he's
got to have distance with my chest
there better be a straight line of
direction between his head and my head
God can hide in the 26th I mentioned for
all I care there better be a straight
line of direction from God to me then he
exists by definition not because I
believe don't believe or maybe I believe
or I don't know if I believe it's got
nothing to do with belief because
there's no provision for belief or
knowledge in the definition of the word
exist and so this was my answer to him
if you understood the mechanism okay
proposed for gravity we're done I mean
if you looked at the mechanism and you
understood it we're done I don't mean
I'm not asking you to believe in it I'm
asking you to understand I achieve my
goal whether you believe it and it's
been proven to you that is your personal
opinion it doesn't concern science if
instead you did not understand the
mechanism gravity then you should ask
for a clarification
but to make a vague statement regarding
not finding anything relevant amounts to
well truly that's what it is and he's a
troll all you had to do was look at the
picture you have two choices there and
you either stay precisely in your own
words what you understood or did it of
whatever you read or you challenge the
mechanism it's exposed in irrational and
explicit manner okay so that was my
answer he's gotta tell me what he didn't
understand he can't just say well you
didn't put anything relevant in there
well I don't know what you read I don't
know if you even saw the picture I mean
with what was there to read a one
paragraph I mean I don't know maybe he's
got a Twitter mind yeah you know one
liners that's all you can really
continues in this debate and I'm taking
snapshots that I can't put it all out
there
what is your rope it is a concept okay
not an object it's my famous rope take
it to all my conferences this is a
concept I thought it was it looks like
an object to me I mean I could draw a
rope and if you don't believe me I mean
you know you can go down the internet
and look up the word Google grope and
see if you get any pictures or go to the
hardware store and ask you know the man
there and say did you give me a two
strand rope hopefully gives you
something in your hand to take back with
you okay and instead this guy is gonna
say that and hold on I got a whole lot
to say this he says that force is a
physical object you'll see that in a
second it is a concept not an object
there is no such thing in nature what
there's no such thing in nature he says
what the hell it is fiction generate is
a product of the smart mind of Bill
Gates oh my god you know so uh so we got
a problem right there you know he
doesn't think that a rope is a physical
object we got it we got a serious
problem there and so what do I answer
say well hey Rupe any rope weather here
on earth or on Mars or in the land of
the Klingons has shape that's the key
point
an object is that which has shaped the
word rope always without exception
refers to that which has shaped anywhere
in the universe shape is the only
universal attribute of objects but if
you know a rope that doesn't have shake
please bring it to the conference only
then can we confirm your claim that a
rope is a concept otherwise he's got to
define what an object is and what a
concept is and he did give it his best
shot poor guy he gave the word object
his best shot and that also blew my mind
okay so he continued and he says
nonsense a rope hypothesis is a concept
now he changed the argument he said it
was the hypothesis that is a concept
because as a hypothesis it comes from
within a force be an expense as
something real outside is an object
he actually said this he says a rope
forces an object but a rope but of
course he changed the argument he said
he is it's the hypothesis which is the
contour I know how pathes is a concept
but a rope rope is an object but he'd
ever addressed that but instead we made
it worse he just said that a force is an
object now we really have a problem
because this person doesn't understand
the difference between objects and
concept he thinks love is a physical
object he thinks a heart is a concept
it's I thought it was the other way
around at least you know okay so uh what
does he do with this concept called
force he does miracles with it he says
an Apple falls to the earth why good
question why is there a rope connecting
the Apple to some something distant the
experimental philosopher that's him
right finds out by taking the Apple in
his palm he feels that the Apple son
somehow pushed against his palm okay
by something unknown no rope here yeah
see the road right you can't touch it
because an object is not that which you
can touch or see the objects that which
has shape so if the experimental
philosopher is expecting to see and
touch you know with his eyes in his
hands and his ears and his mouth and his
nose well he's gonna run into trouble
because Mother Nature specifically made
the rope invisible and untouchable so
you can't you can't approach it through
an experiment experimental philosopher
know the only way you can approach it is
through the mind you can only visualize
it because you're trying to visualize
the mechanism that's what you're trying
to visualize not the Rope you're trying
to see how mother needs to do your
tricks okay
experimental philosopher calls the
unknown something that locally makes the
Apple heavy against the palm by the name
weight others call it gravity and yeah
it's these people who believe that
weight is equal to Newton's second law
which is mass times in this case
acceleration this specific gravitation
acceleration is the acceleration of
gravity on here on earth that's what the
G stands for and that's not true weight
is not equal to mass times gravitational
the gravitational G gave the little G
there which is 9.8 meters per second
squared and that's not weight weight is
a static concept it's location specific
okay so this is what he's saying he says
I hold the Apple in this case the ball
right in my hand and I have all these
particles hitting on it okay that's what
he's gonna be thinking about okay and I
put the ether behind it just because
this is what these people are thinking
that there's some kind of body of
particles in the universe that somehow
is pressing the Apple against his hand
that's what he's got in mind okay and
and so it continues give me a second
here and put him up there and he says
because right now he's holding it he's
holding you Apple right with him ball
right now he's gonna move it now he
opens
Paul okay the Apple falls to the ground
yeah
Apple Mountain falls what is the cause
of that motion good question do not
feign a hypothetical pulling rope still
no rope here and no pool he knows for
sure there's no pool that it's all push
and he says it the cause of the apples
motion cannot be seen can't see it but
he's trying to do an experimental the
experimental philosopher calls that
cause a force which is obviously an
object in his mind which is just another
word for cause that's the cause the
force when push the cart is the force
not the nettle farmer okay which is just
another word for cause okay evidently
this force is not a hypothetical concept
but a real entity so he thinks that
force is an entity a thing of an object
a body or whatever whatever he thinks up
to an object is a thing is it can be
identified by the really observable
effect motion it really generates so
he's trying to figure out what the the
in other words he he comes to the notion
of force indirectly by watching
something that he can see and touch and
he said well something moved it I'll
call that a force and it's got to be an
object because it calls that in effect
so it's got to be an object on the other
hand my rope you know that's not an
object that's a concept that's an
assumption that's uh that's make-believe
that's a superposition so none of that
has anything to do with his version of
you know experimental philosophy this
force can be identified in the same way
as when a stone comes through your
window so now a force is a stone he
treats it like icy streets it like a
physical object just like the route in
this three Titans of physical hubs and
say they worked I'm you know the same
thing then they deny it then they said
now that's not what I meant you
misunderstood you have to take math to
understand what I said
okay through your window from the
outside you know you know we always know
in mathematical physics that it must
have been thrown he's talking about push
okay that is there must have been a call
outside generating the motion of the
stone okay so what is he saying he's
saying this he's saying from the
experience so push this is all don't
push it's the only if the force that
exists in mathematical physics a don't
have pool at all the experiment in
experimenter knows no they always know
ok the force of push is proportional to
the generated motion double the push
double the velocity etc he also knows
they always know if you repeatedly push
something its motion growth swifter and
Swifter analogously the velocity of the
falling Apple which accelerates in the
course of fall must be caused by a
succession of pushes in time all this
guy ever learned is push and that's all
that mathematical physicists have ever
learned and that's why they used
particles because that's what they use
to push those invisible ether particles
that's what pushes okay so the this is
the only way they understand it they
understand it as a push they never
understand it as a pull and and so here
this is this is how is he visualizes
this yeah he says here's the particle
and that's being pushed by particles
coming down so so here you have this
ball it's being pushed by particles and
there aren't there have to be ever more
particles pushing on it because the
particle the the ball accelerates
towards the earth the gravitation
gravitation is an acceleration so it's
got to have more and more particles
pushing and as time goes by okay so
that's never been explained with
particles okay so what I say is well
what if we do make a new assumption
instead of particles we pull and we pull
right through the hand when it's
standing still will the ball to stand
you still that's why he feels pressure
on the hand gives it's being pulled
right through his hand okay and why does
it fall when he takes his hand away well
here we have it okay you see what's
happening every atom
of the ball is connected to every atom
on earth including the horse and as it
falls the ropes fan out and so there are
more effective ropes and therefore there
is the therefore you have the
explanation for acceleration what do we
mean by effective ropes well here's a
picture of it okay let me get back in
here okay
you have you have two objects cylinder
no key - okay whatever box and you have
every one two three four five in the
same axis as on the same axes in nine
number six which is from the other
object as the cylinder moved closer the
ropes fan out and now each one acts
independently we call those independent
ropes that were not independent in the
first case we call those effective ropes
now we have more effective ropes as the
two objects approach each other
notice we didn't create matter out of
thin air what we did is change the
distance which is what Newton's equation
says you've changed the distance you
change the force which is not a force
really in the case of gravitation it's
known as tension but they never learned
that either and they think the tension
is a force okay so here we have it okay
you see three guys Andy Charlie and Bob
this isn't the book by the way and you
have Charlie holding the center of the
rope that these two guys are tucking and
let's say let's say Eddie is tugging
from Bob and a force or really attention
but bukata force no problem force of ten
X whatever X is we don't care we're in
the land of the Klingons they have a
different measuring system over there so
we got 10 X can Charlie pull at 10x
strength or force both from Andi and
from Bob at the same time now if he
pulls from Andi he's favoring Bob and he
pulls
from Bobby's in favor in the Andy the
only way he does he can pull on both or
not pull on either is by simply be in
the center and being irrelevant here and
iam Bob are pulling on each other and
Charlie could be in existence as far as
they concerned the only way we noticed
Charlie's presence if he steps aside
from outside of the axis now he's
pulling a 10x from each one of these
guys now you feel his presence when he
was in the center he can't pull from
both guys and so it says if he wasn't
there at all and that's the issue with
the atoms here you have atoms a C and B
and C as it is it exists it doesn't
exist for all practical purposes because
you don't feel its weight its mass its
whatever all you all it feels is B the
only way you were gonna feel C is if it
steps out of line then we feel it you
can do this with a rubber band you can
not because it stretches but to get the
sense of what I'm talkin if someone just
holds the center of the rubber band
while you're pulling it apart yeah okay
you put a rubber band yeah and someone
holds the center you don't feel in his
hand the only way you gotta feel his
hands when he pushes it out then you're
gonna feel his tug and you gotta feel
his presence okay that's what it's about
that's what effective ropes relates to
okay so you can prove this to yourself
proof evidence in your own dark basement
and so here is the synthesis of that you
have Newton's gravitational equation
which has nothing to do with force it
only has to do with tension and tension
is not a force force someone wins the
tug-of-war whether it's push or pull
tension no one wins the tug-of-war
there's a big difference and the
mathematicians never figured that out
they think tension is a force because
they think of something like you know
rubberband being stretched to the limit
or something and so what does that
equation tell us there tells us that
there's two objects object one and
object two and they're separated that's
what
it is and the farther they are away the
closer the ropes get to each other in
other words the more they merge and you
can see at the bottom what happens when
too close together the ropes and out
when the farther about apart they act
like a single coaxial that's what
effective ropes means and that explains
the mechanism of gravity right there you
need know to know more than that do you
believe it that's your problem that's
totally your problem I'm explaining your
mechanism whether you believe it or not
that your personal business that's your
religion I mean I don't care it doesn't
concern science okay so that's when mr.
head he changed this tune a little bit
right right perhaps the Apple could be
tugged for the first time he pondered
that possibility
it kind of clicked that it could be
targeted it doesn't have to be pushed
maybe it's pull right through the hand
or perhaps not who knows knows I don't
care about knows you make an assumption
to understand the mechanism and he's
talking about knowledge provided there
that there would be something pulling if
this is really the case nobody knows
this is not a question now is this is a
question of assumptions you have to make
an assumption about the invisible
entities that mother nature uses to do
gravity magnetism light all these
invisible
you know tricks that she does you need
to make an assumption you you can't go
to the lab and say oh I'm gonna see if I
can see it or touch it and even if if
you run an experiment you're gonna
deduce it indirectly you're gonna see
something visible in touchable and
you're gonna say well then something
moved it or something affected or
something was in contact with it well
you gotta identify that something and
they say well I don't see it in and it's
not real because I gotta imagine it and
so they don't think it's an object
because they they can't touch it or see
it and they have to imagine it they say
it said it's an abstract or or a
spiritual object now it's an invisible
untouchable intangible object that's
what it is all objects that mother
nature uses or mediators that she uses
are invisible and intensive
I imagine mother nature would have made
air visible I mean you know of mother
nature of God and father universe all
trio got of them got together together
with the devil you know four of them at
the bar and they said look okay we're
gonna make some people dumb or maybe
we're gonna make some people whether it
is an experimental philosophers but we
can't make them all blind and if we make
air visible then that's all they would
see you know you would see Aaron at all
times in front of your eyes so they in
your smart way fortunately but not like
these experimental [ __ ] philosophers
they said no in our wise wisdom right
love of wisdom we're gonna make err
invisible and that's just fine because
now we can see and likewise you know if
mother nature made the Rope that binds
any two atoms visible in tangible
everything would be tied in knots so she
was very E or they all for although
you're getting a double they were smart
they said look we're in our wise wisdom
what we're gonna do is make them
invisible and intangible that way no one
gets tripped when he walks and Don gets
tied up in knots so they are invisible
intangible in smell inheritable in
testable they have all the ins and outs
you can't touch a rug you can't
determine this through an experiment
that's why experiments have nothing to
do with science in science you got to
sit back and theorize that's what
science is you got to give me a rational
explanation for that mechanism and this
goes over their heads because this is
not what they've been taught in school
by rote Empire through Authority okay
okay so here when you say ward you get
this thing that atoms go right through
your hand you know stick out you know we
have a professor Richard Muller of
Berkeley University he says for example
if you have the earth there's a big mass
here you can see the mass the Big M
that's the
earth big mass and you have you with
your little mass here every atom on
earth is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it the amazing
thing about gravity is that it goes
right through things so why did I put
the ropes coming out of their hand right
you know connected to the ball right
through my hand because that's exactly
what he's described there every atom is
pulling on you you're pulling on it
gravity goes through things and well at
least uh mr. ed was able to figure
something out you know he was at least a
little wise here and he says the answer
is he says not that the amazing thing
about gravity is that it does not go
through things correct because it is
already there he doesn't even know what
he's said there he hasn't he hasn't read
his own sentence it is already there I
keep that in mind by experience it
exists already everywhere in space so it
must not go from a source to a place
where to act under gravitating body but
he's using our push force certainly made
of particles in his mind and he's saying
it pushes it put the ball is pushed or
the Apple is pushed against his hand but
he's saying it doesn't go anywhere he's
aware of that he knows that it's already
there
it doesn't move it doesn't go through
things it doesn't move through things
because it's already there what else
could it be if this if it's already
connected if every atom is already
connect it doesn't have to go of course
he's totally right gravity is not a
motion thing because weight is a static
concept okay
and so here's the illustration of that
I've got that in my book and here you
have yeah interconnected atoms there you
have it it's all ready there we're not
throwing balls that move through the air
to produce
now gravity is a tug because the ropes
are all connected all atoms in the
universe are interconnected and they go
right through things because they're
already there as he well said so you
know what can I say no second here so
what do we have for mr. ed well I think
mr. Ed's not really a horse I think he's
a mule I've been talking to a mule all
these days I think you know what can I
say these are the people who run the
world
they sometimes complain about their
colleagues they say oh you [ __ ] look
you believe in space-time in black holes
in Big Bang and they believe in bigger
nonsense so yeah I think I wasn't
talking to a horse I was talking to Emil
what can I say these people don't
understand the scientific method that's
what it's all about
they run with this scientific method
that they developed in the 17th century
people like Galileo and Newton and they
say oh experiments that win we need
experiments in equations that science in
terms of equations and experiments have
nothing at all to do with science
no in science we have to explain that's
what you have to break your brain and I
always give the example you go to the
show and you watch the magician cut the
lady in half to pieces curtains closed
curtains open and your girl comes out
tada one piece in this universe in
another universe I guess that she's cut
in half that's the way that's the
explanation of mathematical physics
would give you but
so yes the mathematician next to you you
say how did he do that and the guy says
oh I can tell you perfectly
ok how do you do it well he took a saw
and he cut the lady in 2 pieces and it
took 10 strokes of the saw and he did it
in 15
that's how he did it well I was trying
to ask how he did the trick and what a
numerical nonsense measurement saying oh
the acceleration of gravity is 9.8
meters per second squared that doesn't
tell me what gravity is specifically it
doesn't tell me why the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system I need a
physical interpretation for that
phenomenon and a phenomenon is that the
Sun twirls the earth around itself
because every atom of the Sun is
connected to every atom that makes up
the earth now we can understand gravity
because you know the the and why the
earth goes more or less in a circle or
ellipse whatever around the Sun because
it's physically bound to the Sun and we
can also explain the elliptical orbit
because the Sun is moving around the
Milky Way and obviously when the you
know cowboy running on his horse around
the circle moves his lasso around you
know that wire also stretches and that's
that's why it's not a perfect circle and
why isn't the moon fly out of the earth
because of the same reason every atom
that comprises the moon is tied to every
atom comprising the earth the earth
swings the moon around itself now do you
believe that there are ropes
electromagnetic rows I didn't ask you to
believe I'm asking you to understand the
mechanism of why of how mechanism cause
the moon doesn't fly out of the solar
system do you understand the mechanism
that I'm proposing if you do we're done
we're finished with science now you can
believe whatever you want if you don't
then you got to ask me a question of you
know what it is that you didn't
understand of that mechanism you know
here here we use the yeah yeah okay so
this is why the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system and this is why the
moon doesn't fly out of the solar system
because it better be physically bound
to every atom on earth for else in that
region you're putting spirits you're
doing gravity with spirits if you don't
put anything between the earth and the
moon and you said well I can't see
anything I can't touch any there's
nothing there the astronaut goes out
there he doesn't touch anything
hopefully because mother nature made all
objects that she uses all mediators
invisible and intangible does that mean
they're not objects that that does that
mean they're not real or for that we
need to define the word object and the
footwork real that's what we need to do
before we begin the discussion the word
object that which has shape does this
little thread have shape this this would
be the ropes representing the ropes
those are okay yeah there's a rope and a
shape so we met the condition of object
what does it mean if we say that it
exists it has to have location and
that's a big cat warrant but we'll deal
with that next time anyways we'll see
you on Wednesday
and hopefully I can get back to the
subject matter that I was covered we'll
see that bye bye